breaking news to bring you now and
bernie madoff the financier who pleaded
guilty to organizing
orchestrating the largest ponzi scheme
in history
has died in prison that has been
confirmed in the last few minutes by the
federal
bureau of prisons madoff died at the
federal
medical center in butler in north
carolina
apparently from natural causes
last year his lawyers had filed court
papers to try and get the 82 year old
released from prison
during the covid 19 pandemic saying he
was suffering from
end-stage renal disease and other
chronic medical
conditions that request was denied
and he died in the federal prison he
admitted of course swindling thousands
of clients out of billions of dollars in
investments
over decades at the time of his arrest
fake account statements were telling
clients they had holdings worth
60 billion dollars so bernie madoff
at the financier who pleaded guilty to
organize orchestrating the
biggest ponzi scheme in history has died
in prison